is there a device you can give
uh now that we know the frame
to give to me lex about
how to uh do this podcast better how to
think
about this world how to be a good
engineer
how to uh be a good human being
from take your preoccupation with
suffering seriously
it's a serious business
right and that's part of that to circle
back to the beginning let's say
that's that willingness to gaze into the
abyss which is obviously what you were
doing when you went to ukraine
it's like
it's gazing into the abyss that makes
you better
the thing is and this is maybe where
nietzsche's
idea is not as differentiated as it
became
sometimes your gaze can be forcefully
directed towards the abyss
and then you're traumatized
if it's involuntary and accidental it
can kill you
the more it's voluntary
the more transformative it is and that's
part of that idea about facing death and
hell
it's like
can you tolerate death and hell and the
answer is
this terrible answer is
yes
to the degree that you're willing to do
it
voluntarily and then you might ask well
why should i have to subject myself to
death in hell i'm innocent
and then the answer to that is
even the innocent must be voluntarily
sacrificed to the highest good
that's such an interesting distinction
voluntary stuff voluntary yeah
yeah well that's why the central
christian doctrine is
pick up your cross and follow me
and i'm speaking
not in religious terms saying that i'm
just speaking as a psychologist it's
like one of the things we've learned in
the last hundred years is voluntary
exposure to that which
freezes and terrifies you in measured
proportions
is curative
you